hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video you're going to see
exactly how a rent to rent works
this property is not owned by me it's
not owned by any of my students
it's controlled by one of my students
namely tom
thomas how old are you tom i'm 18 years
old he's 18 years old
18 years old so you don't own it but you
control it i control it yes
how did you take control of this you
must have needed a lot of money no i
only needed a thousand pounds
so a thousand pounds you control the
house yeah
show me around man let's go
okay so this is the first room
as you can see it's a huge room
thick yeah so it kind of the walls and
the room
came in the condition that it's in so we
didn't have to do a lot of work we
didn't have to take the carpets out or
anything
yeah but i had to put in all the
furniture and get the mattresses and
then now
to put all the furniture together you
flat pack this yeah
ikea yep
you have to do it every everyone at some
point that's getting started and
probably
has to get down on their hands and knees
and flat pack yeah
i love doing it so when you spend you
say you put a thousand
is that including the furniture
everything everything costs a thousand
pounds a thousand pounds of sugar on
this property yeah
all right cool well i want to hear that
you know i want to hear the figures of
this
sir i'm paying the landlord 575
for to control the property so okay so
there's no voids for them
guaranteed rent i'm telling it for them
yeah and then the rent that i'm getting
a month
comes to about 1 500 pounds
nice and then my expense is 9.50 so
you're
you're left with about five to six
hundred pound yeah
profit yeah five actually that's decent
bro yeah for the first one i mean
when did you turn 18 just like two
months ago yeah two months ago
okay so tell me then number one
were you scared taking this on you've
now
as an 18 year old got to commit to
paying the landlord 575. is that not
scary
yeah i think the responsibility not not
i wasn't as much scared but more
it was a kick up that bum to basically
your mom was petrified
terrified yeah she lost sleep over it
she was losing sleep
but here's the thing i don't understand
that freaks me out tom your mom was
petrified because why would you betray
because you're gonna have to pay the
landlord 575. yeah
but you've got a break clause six months
after six months because you do it
properly
also if you buy a house you don't have a
great cause
you have to keep paying the mortgage
forever yeah you have to keep paying the
bills forever like
it's it's the least risky way it's like
try before you buy
she'd never done it before and i think
that was what scared her she never
delved into rent to rent and she is
improvising yeah you know so she's got
properties
but this strategy what did you think
when you first heard about rent to rent
as a strategy what happened and tell me
what happened
so i came across it for the first time
on the crash course and i was quite
skeptical
i didn't know what it was i didn't
really understand it like you said my
parents from property they'd never done
it either and that's what scared my mum
yeah but once it was explained really
clearly by yourselves
and the other guys on the crash course
it was a no-brainer to get into it so
i kind of just went from there so how
did you find this property
so we got a letter from a local estate
agent just in the past
basically saying that we did come like
an advert
[Music]
and just mentioned on there they've been
corporate let's yeah and you were like
i've heard this before on the website
respect call them up
and said i've seen this property five
seven five yeah
i'll just take control of it and then um
within about
two or three days i had the keys in my
hand are you kidding me
nope wow okay thousand pounds perfect
how long have you had the keys to this
property how many days a week in a bit
just over a week and how's it going are
you managing to rent the rooms out got
one tenant in we've got another one
coming at the weekend
and i've got three viewings today and
tomorrow dude
and when you say one time in they're
paid then they've played
one wednesday one coming at the weekend
you mean they're actually
moving in as well they're paid as well
dude you've done well
okay you must have been so pumped when
you started renting yeah
yeah that was when i became more
comfortable once i started getting the
rent into the rooms
yeah because that's what people worry
about people worry about getting a rent
to rent
and then not being able to rent the
rooms out yeah what would you say like
what kind of
dude diligence did you learn how to do
before take just taking on
property at random so like on the crash
course you've got spare room
open rent just to kind of check what the
demand is even on
right move you can kind of get a good
gauge of how many properties are rented
in the area
yeah so that was kind of how i did my
due diligence and
it did also help the um i've done
bits looking at properties before my
parents and
i knew what to expect kind of a little
bit with the market round here but still
nothing was certain
yeah this is an area that you're quite
familiar with right
i remember on the crash course we did an
exercise where i said
find the deal and the person who finds
the best deal i'm going to give i said
i'll give a hundred pound cash though
and you actually were like i got a deal
you found a deal i thought i won
what happened so i brought this deal um
i'm still following it through now um
i'm expecting a call
he's turning on the crash course yeah so
i found it on the crap hold him up hold
on hold on
so as a result of the crash course how
much you paid for the crash course
nothing free you're in a free crash
course
you found a property which i said
i'll give the winner 100 pounds to yeah
and and and you thought you'd wonder you
thought you'd be 100. you didn't but
you're actually now buying it
yeah sick and you've got this property
all of it is a result of a free one-day
virtual crash course yeah i wasn't happy
that i didn't win but i'm going to get
the real prize
you know what i said to you though on
the day i remember saying if you don't
win the hundred pound and you miffed
don't worry because the hundred pound
isn't the real price the real price is
success and it's
learning it so this is probably what the
smallest room
yeah and it's still big yeah this is
still big um
i had to put this bed together as well
get the mattress
this came with it so this is great this
is quite a big storage unit
yeah for the tenant moving in um using
wardrobe yes he's a student
what what who are these hymns
are they all students no professionals
like what's the story
so the first um guy that's already moved
in he's a professional
yeah he's from poland and then the
second one that's coming in
here is a post grad study at the
the university right you know what you
know what i said about
um postgrads not two but being careful
mixing professionals and students
have you heard me say this yeah good so
you know like not to mix
an 18 year old student with a
professional
with a dss yeah cool cool cool because
sometimes actually i know you're writing
these rooms out real fast
but sometimes fast is good
but what's really not good is fast but
with the wrong tenants
no yeah i think definitely because the
last thing you want is
either someone in that isn't paying
something that's disrupting or you want
quiet happy times two problems you can
have a rental rents
one problem is you can't fill the rooms
that's a big problem second problem you
can have if you fill the room to the
wrong people that's an even bigger
problem yeah
you've clearly not had the first problem
you're renting the rooms out great
um but you just need to make sure are
you vetting the tenants properly yeah
yeah we're doing it i guess
anybody away uh we've turned a couple
people away yeah that's good
cool man what's next
so we have got the final bedroom
yeah so is this one rented out yes this
one's already tenanted
okay we don't have to go up we don't
have to go up there i mean
is he here we can't he's not here is he
happy for us to go up yeah he's already
said that we can go in um
let's go
[Music]
stairs
i had to paint this whole room myself it
was kind of like
a bit of a dirty color so i'd just go
over it just to make it look all fresh
we don't like dirty colors no
sir and then the carpet was actually
there was
three different carpets in here all
different colours
so i can imagine this look pretty awful
yeah it didn't look great
i think where the room is in the house
is probably my favorite
yeah now especially for a house [ __ ] i
think some people just want to be away
from everyone else
how much how much is the guy paying his
is he actually renting this now this is
his house
yeah how much is he paying so he's
paying 85 pounds a week for it so about
what three six
eight yeah a month see when you do this
a long time you know the math yeah
you know you can just when you start out
when you start out you times it by four
when you get a bit professional you
times it by four point three three three
and when you get really seasoned you
just know it in your head because you
don't know in times
you'll get there so okay so this this is
right now for three six eight yeah
um what about the other what about the
other one that you just rented how much
is that renting for
so the other one that's a 80s 80 oh jeez
now i'm gonna make myself look bad
all right i'm gonna have to be i'm gonna
have to just be a professional and not
seasoned
80 times 4.333 is
three four six okay cool so three six
eight three four six what about the
other two rooms
so they're both the same at 90 90 okay
and you've got a lot of interest in that
yeah i've had a lot of interest a lot
how long recommended
before this whole thing just rented it
out
i've given myself the target of the end
of the week so and you only got the keys
last week
yeah that's so good okay so it's going
to be 90
um so you're going to get in total
389 plus three eight nine
plus three four six plus three six
eight so you're expected to make about
one four nine two yeah so sound about
right yes
you're gonna have to pay five seven five
five seven five direct to the
landlord she's gonna leave you with 917
but you can have other costs as well
what else
yeah so i've got to pay the council tax
yeah to pay the water gas and electric
yeah i've also got to put money aside
for repairs and voids
yes um and then there's also a small
wi-fi bill as well so that
brings me to 550 a month cool so you're
going to be left with a profit of 550
per month what would you say to someone
that said can't they just pay their
own bills can't they just pay their own
well i would say would be
um the reason that i i teach not to do
that and for you to pay the landlord is
2021 the thing that sells is convenience
yeah people want to just move into a
property that's already
furnished there's already the bells
there's fast wi-fi
yeah there's there's nice paint on the
wall they just you know they want
convenience they'll live here for like
12 months and then move out
so paying the bills it kind of defeats
the objective renting a room
um but no man that's really great that's
really really really great
so you got this you've been making about
500 pound a month profit off the whole
property
do they have to share like share the
bathroom and share this
can i see the kitchen because that's an
important room especially if they're
sharing it it needs to be a decent
a decent room i'm surprised how well the
area is doing they're here yeah we're in
the middle of a lockdown
we're in huddersfield and this dude's
running out rooms faster than you can
like rent them out in london okay
so relatively new and clean yeah yeah it
is
and the kitchen's on the on the first
floor as well
the kitchen is just through here
yeah decent so do you need a license for
this no i don't need a license
it's only for bed do you need any
planning permission nope
um did you have to go through references
when you when you got this how did the
letter management work
uh yeah so they did all their checks on
us and stuff okay so
this is where your you put your parents
down yeah okay
great what would you say to somebody
that's saying it's all right for you
because your parents could be a
guarantor for you but i haven't got
parents that'll be a guarantor
it doesn't have to be a parent it can be
anyone that you
you've got a network you've got to find
anyone else that's interested in
property it could be a friend it could
just a stranger that you can't not
strange but someone else that's
interested in property
yeah what's been the hardest thing about
getting this property and getting up and
running
um i don't think any of it's been as
hard as i thought it was going to be
i think once i got all the flat packing
done all the rooms were ready
and i advertised as fast as i could and
i did the best adverts and put it in as
most place
as possible all the inquiries came to me
and then it was just a case of getting
people interviewed as
many as possible as fast as possible
what would you say
was the breakdown of the thousand pounds
so
you had to pay presumably 575 rent up
front one month what else
um so i also have uh
the furniture that was probably the
biggest expense how much was that
about 300 quid okay yeah and then i had
to pay
for the painting for the top room i had
to
pay my friends a little bit to help put
the furniture together
yeah um and then i had to pay for the
carpet to be fit as well in the top room
as well was there a deposit as well
no i didn't have to pay a deposit really
really yeah so there's no deposit
that's crazy you're doing really well
thank you you're feeling proud yeah
what's the plan now moving forward um
kind of rinse and repeat just do the
same again um
especially while i don't have loads of
money i'm not really working at the
moment because of
what's going on with curvid i'll be back
to work soon in the next couple weeks
now that there's been
what do you do what is your what is your
job sir i'm a qualified swimming teacher
i do that um at the weekends
i also get paid to play rugby as well
and then
any sort of odd jobs that i can get to
kind of get a little bit more money to
save i'll do
so so how much do you get paid to be a
swimming teacher
uh so that's um about 100 pounds a week
so about 450 a month yeah so this will
pay you more than you're swimming
yeah how does that make you feel good
because it's a lot harder being a super
teacher
yeah and don't get me wrong this will
come with work i'm sure
you're gonna have to manage it keep the
tenants happy and some people say you
know oh it's just rent to rent it's just
a job but it's like well
every if you want to make money if you
haven't got money to invest initially
okay you're at a thousand pounds
you it's gonna need work yeah you know
but this is gonna build your experience
it's gonna build up your money um you
put down a thousand pounds
making 500 pounds a month the return on
investment on that well let's work it
out
now of course you've got a time return
on investment 550 a month times 12
and you've made you've been factored in
maintenance
repairs voids all that stuff yes so 660
you put down 500 so divided by so you
put down a thousand
so the return on investment
is 660 percent yeah which is incredible
so massive massive congrats tell me
about this other property that you've
got as well the one that you found on
the crash course
yeah so the offers currently going
through for that i'm expecting a call
back today
what are you gonna do with it i'm gonna
package up and sell it to an investor
boom what would you say someone was
thinking of doing the crash course but
was feeling skeptical like you were
get on it were you very skeptical yes
tell me about that um just
i didn't know what to expect at all when
i found out it was 12 hours i was like
is it all gonna be filled with good
stuff yeah it was
it was all valuable stuff i've filled a
whole notepad full of nuts
yeah so as a result you've got a
property that you're selling now
packaging you've got a rent to rent
you're doing some cool stuff with your
mom and dad yeah
so absolutely awesome best advice top
tips someone watching this maybe they're
also
18. you just donated a couple months if
it's crazy yeah but maybe they're also
18
looking to get started might only have a
thousand pounds like you to the name
what do you do what's your advice top
tips get on the crash course get some
training and then take
action yeah i think a lot of people
might do the training i might come on
the crash course and then think about
doing something and think and think
but i think the best thing is just to go
and do yeah and listen guys the crash
course you can have a free ticket from
me
absolutely free in the description i'll
leave a link
get booked on for free tom how do we how
do we find you out on are you on
instagram and stuff yeah so i'm on
instagram um
at your property zone or at
tom.christian love it good stuff
check him out he's going to be very very
very successful i look forward to seeing
you the crash course are you going to be
back at the crash course yeah i'm going
to be there come down see
tom see me i'll leave a link in the
description get booked on it's free
there's a one pound booking fee to check
you're a real person get booked on you
want to see more videos like this
check them out right here you want a
ticket to the crash course i'm going to
make it really easy for you you can get
a ticket right here
and don't forget to subscribe you can do
that right here thanks so much
see you next time